All right, guys.
So that we're not going to run over,
my name's Valerie Weaver.
I am the chair of this major symposia on understanding the impact of
mechanobiology on tumor evolution.
I wanted to point out, there's two things that you can do.
You can ask questions here at the mic, or you can also
scan that barcode, and you could type your questions in.
So for anyone that's online or anyone who's in other rooms,
scan in the barcode quickly because that slide's going to
disappear very quickly. And I also want
to indicate that I'm very grateful that the
AACR has given us the opportunity to have this symposium.
Okay. So without further ado, I'm going to give a small
intro. So look, for those of you that are not as familiar with things like
mechanics,
I would argue that we live in a physical world.
I don't think anybody here doesn't understand the concept of
gravity. Okay?
So basically, how do I...
Oh, I know.
Okay. So what I would say, too, is that it's not just gravity.
All living cells, we're like big mechanical machines.
And our heart pumps, and the blood goes through the vessels.
You experience basically shear forces.
When you walk around, your bones are expressing compression stresses.
Those forces are percolating all the way down to the single cell level.
And our cells everywhere in our body, not just our muscle cells, are doing
a lot of work every day, all the time, to maintain the
homeostasis and health of that tissue.
When you have a tumor, however, what you sense if you go in and you
actually physically palpate the tissue is that it's actually stiffer.
And basically, what I would point out is that there are techniques
like MR imaging elastography, where you can see all the stiffness
here, sonoelastography for breast. You see that for prostate.
You see that for pancreas. They've even used it, if you will, to
actually classify pancreatic cancers into different subtypes.
Now, if you go down and look at the actual
sort of pathophysiology and where these forces actually arise,
you can imagine if you have a ductal tissue, for example, as the
cells begin to actually populate and fill in these ducts,
there's going to be a lot of cell stress.
But the matrix is changing around those developing lesions, so you
have a lot of stiffening, and then you have reciprocal tension
that's acquired. And then as the cells
invade and interact with that matrix, they're experiencing a very different
physical milieu. And once they get into the
circulation or in the lymphatics, once again, they're
experiencing very different physical cues that alter
their physiology. And once they get to their metastatic sites, once
again, the actual mechanical cues or physical
cues that they're experiencing are quite different.
Now, there was a really nice review that I would suggest people
could look at, was written by Rakesh Jain's group, where
he basically defines the kinds of forces that cells experience,
including solid stress, fluid pressure, stiffness, the
microarchitecture of the microenvironment, and the idea is that it has all
this pleiotropic effects on various different cues or
different behaviors of the tumor cells.
There's been a lot of work over the last three decades really elaborating
out all the different pathways, and I'm not going to spend my time here
exploring that. Simply to say that
at least in some groups of researchers, there's now a
general appreciation the mechanotransduction affects everything from
anti-tumor immunity,
epithelial-mesenchymal transition, stem cell behavior and
expansion,
migration, invasion, metabolic changes, angiogenesis,
et cetera.
What I would say is that we, as a community in the mechano field, have
spent an inordinate amount of time of defining these forces,
assessing the impact of these forces on tumor progression,
clarifying molecular mechanisms, looking at the impact on anti-tumor
immunity, et cetera. I would say that part of the
field, and this is what this particular session is about, has begun to
move into the realm of the tumor genome, genotype, the
genome. This is also happening in the stem cell field and in
normal tissue development, and we have two speakers today.
I will start off on one aspect, and then Dennis
Discher from UPenn will actually go into more about genomic
instability.
I would argue, though, that for the whole community to really
embrace the concept of mechanotransduction and
mechanics in tumors, that we need, as a
group, to move towards clinical translation. Okay?
We need to think about diagnostics and prognostic indicators.
Certainly, Rakesh and other people have tried to improve drug
delivery, improve immune therapy, and we
have one talk where I've enticed Christina Curtis to begin
to embrace the concept of mechanics,
and she's going to talk to us about that.
But I will end this intro by actually making a
plea or a sort of prediction, if you will.
And my perspective is that in about 10 years, I really,
truly believe that the research community and the
clinical community will really begin to embrace the idea of force in
cancer, and they will understand that not considering
force in cancer is like trying to treat and cure
cancer half-blind. So I will begin my
presentation on forcing inflammation to initiate malignancy and
drive tumor progression. I have no disclosures, and I will
start by really outlining the idea that it
doesn't matter what solid cancer you look atIn all
cases, they develop some type of fibrosis.
And this level of fibrosis, whether it's breast, lung,
pancreas, liver, kidney, I'm just giving some examples,
those individuals with a lot of fibrosis have by far the worst
prognosis.
And so our question has been not just does it drive
progression,
but can a stiff or fibrotic stroma increase or
induce mutations to drive malignancy?
Is it doing something more sort of
hardwiring the cancer, if you will?
And then more at the end, could force act as a tumor
initiator?
So the way that we went about this is one of my postdocs, Mary Kate Hayward,
worked with Conor Stashko on some clinical pathologists, and we had
a whole cohort of patient samples, in which we bin them into low and high
fibrosis. We did stiff maps and other analysis to
show that those that had high fibrosis were also
stromal had was stiffer. And what Conor Stashko did was
availed himself of a lot of these
datasets, and he could show that if you have a really high fibrosis score, you
also have a high amount of tumor mutational
burden, which we thought was rather intriguing.
And we could show very clearly in these tissues that DNA
double breaks at least, correlated beautifully with where
the regions of the most stiffness were.
And we did a lot of work to show that it's not strictly just proliferation.
So of course, we turned to experimental models to try to address this, and what
Mary Kate did was we have ways of reducing the tension in the
tissue. In this case, we have LOX conditional knockouts, and we also have function
blocking antibodies and pharmaceutical treatment.
You reduce the fibrosis in models like polyoma.
You show that there's less fibrillar collagen.
You show that the stiffness goes down.
You show that you can reduce metastases.
And lo and behold, you reduce the load of these DNA double strand
breaks. Okay, so that's nice. We take it another step and we
take pieces of P53 mutant
breast tissue. I'm just showing you here today only in breast, but this is not
just confined to breast, where we can put them in a soft or stiff
cross-linked matrix, put them into a mouse, and then we wait.
And 25 weeks, in some case, we wait over a year.
And what Mary Kate was able to show was what, of course, you increase the
stiffness of that tissue,
you increase the amount of metastases.
But what was gratifying that she could see is that you really increase
this mutational load or this-- no, not mutational, sorry, DNA double
strand breaks. Okay. So we then went and Conor
Stashko did some analysis, and he showed that with a Jivas score,
that in the stiff, there was a huge increase in double strand breaks.
We work with Hugo and Valentina, his trainee,
and they really analyzed with whole exome sequencing, and what we could
show or what they showed, if I would say, is that the number of genes
with basically frameshift mutations were actually
hugely, significantly increased in the tumors that arose in the stiff
environment.
So what was more intriguing is what Hugo and Valentina were able to
see is that there was a disproportionate increase in frameshift
mutations in many of these known breast cancer tumor suppressor genes.
This KMT2D is actually a metastasis suppressor.
And so what Mary Kate then did was she obtained an antibody that
actually did not recognize where the mutation would be, but only if it was
a wild type. And what she was able to show is that,
basically, the ability to detect this metastasis
suppressor was greatly reduced in those tissues
that arose in a stiffer environment that had higher metastatic
frequency. And if you took a polyoma, which has very
high metastases, and you inhibited the stiffness,
now you can actually detect more of this particular suppressor.
So that was nice. And it at least suggests a little bit
that says maybe the stiffness could influence DNA
damage, perhaps.
We know it affects the ECM, we know it affects metastases
in terms of invasion. So we took it a step further and we asked,
"Well, what's driving that?" Because then that might give us some clues.
We know there's a compelling relationship between inflammation and
cancer. And what basically we had shown several years ago
is the increasing phenotype or aggressive
phenotype of breast cancers has higher infiltrating immune cells and
CD68 positive cells. We showed there's a correlation between
the stiffness and CD68. And then by facts
analysis, what Brian Rafal, when he was working with Lisa, showed was they were
all very highly correlated with pro-tumor myeloid cells.
So when Mary Kate looked at her soft versus stiff
tumors, what she showed was not surprisingly, there were more
macrophages coming into the stiff tumors.
There were more neutrophils coming into the stiff tumors.
And part of that was because there was an increase in things like
phospho-STAT3. Now, this was
associated with increase in a lot of these cytokines
that actually stimulate the influx.
She did the opposite, either knocking out or reducing
the activity of lys oxidase. It reduced phospho-STAT
levels, and we see the same thing with the STAT knockout, and of course, it
also reduced the level of many of these key cytokines.
We don't think that this is confined just to experimental models
because when we looked at patient samples, irrespective of
HR status, there was a very huge increase in
things like phospho-STAT3 and myosin activity.
And basically this was beautifully correlated where the regions of
stiffness had the highest influx or increase in
phospho-STAT.Okay, so we took it a step further, and we went
to patient data sets where there's a tumor-associated
macrophage signature that
Jeff Polar developed many years ago, and we assessed that in the
context of tumor fibrosis. And what Connor was able to
show is that there was a high,
basically, mutational score associated with
this TAM GVA score associated with high stiffness and
fibrosis.
And this again, CD163, for example, was highly,
highly correlated with regions of stiffness.
Okay, so what we are now putting together is that you have this stiff
environment, and we think this actually activates pathways,
including phosphostat three. I'm sure there's many others.
We believe that this drives up pro-inflammatory cytokines, brings
in and enhances the inflammatory infiltrate.
Very different molecules coming from these inflammatory cells coming
in, they help to stimulate the CAFs,
and this, of course, changes the matrix, and we believe that this
contributes in part to the basically mutational load.
So how is that happening? So we and others know that ROS, of
course, it's been implicated coming out of these myeloid cells.
But of course, if you look and you take primary myeloid cells, and
you basically pop them on the soft and stiff, you could show they have more ROS.
Okay. But ROS, it's very
reactive. It doesn't percolate through the tissues.
It's very unstable. So instead, one needs to think
more
carefully. And what you have is these lipid
peroxides, which actually then decay and actually
drive lipid aldehydes. So when Mary Kate
looked, she could show that you have more of these lipid ROS that
comes up in a stiff. But more importantly, when you go into these tumors that we're
developing the stiff, what you see is there's an increase
in lipid ROS in the CD45, CD11b
cells. Okay, so that's kind of nice.
So how and what's going on here? So you have lipid peroxidation,
and when you look at lipid peroxidation, you can look in the cells, and you see
that there's more oxidized phospholipids.
And you could detect this higher in the stiff environments.
Okay. Moreover, what we also could observe
is that when you repress the stiffness, you repress the influx of these
cells, you reduce the amount of oxidized DNA.
If you increase the stiffness, you increase the load of
oxidized DNA.
And you could take it a step further, and we can show-- We did a bunch of
lipid aldehydes, but here I'm showing you hydroxynonenal, lipid
peroxide-derived aldehydes, again, as shown here in
pink.
When you actually, over time, in a stiff environment,
the tissues acquire a lot more of these lipid aldehydes.
Okay, so the first question is, can you increase DNA damage
by
elevating these lipid peroxides and things to drive tumor
progression? So to do that, what we did was crossed
in a GPX4 knockout because there are these
GPXs that actually prevent or reduce the
load, if you will, of these lipid aldehydes.
And so she crossed that into basically a
myeloid
line. And what she could show is that basically, this
elevates the level of lipid
oxidation, and what she shows that even in a
soft, it cranks up the level of oxidized
DNA,
and increases the load of these HMEs. Okay.
Moreover, what she was able to show is that the metacyclic lesions
were really cranked up pretty highly,
and this was accompanied by an increase in a lot of this DNA damage
marks.
So then she did the ops, and we collaborated with Joe Witzmann.
He's down here in San Diego, and he has this really cool mouse
model. It's EO6 that makes these Fabs that actually mop up
these lipid aldehydes. And Mary Kate crossed this with a
polyoma model.
And what she showed is that it really mopped up-- All these oxidized
DNA went way down. The lipid aldehydes went way
down. And when she looked more, what she could see is the DNA
damage marks also went down.
And basically, the tumor epithelium, there was hardly
any tumors that were developing in these mice.
What was happening in concert with a lot of these changes,
in the stiffness, we were seeing increases in
basically
excision repair and NES.
And so the idea here is that in a soft, you have less
of these bulky DNA addicts that are forming because you have less
of these, basically, lipid aldehydes, and in a stiff,
that's higher. And so our working hypothesis has been that there's persistent
overwhelming lipid aldehyde-induced oxidative DNA damage
produced in part by the myeloid cells, and this exceeds NER
capacity, and this may actually lead to an accumulated
mutations within key tumor suppressors or oncogenes.
But of course, we want to know if this is relevant for patients.
And so when Mary Kate worked with colleagues and looked at the oxidized
DNA, what she showed is in patient samples,
she sees a huge increase that correlates with the regions of
stiffness of oxidized DNA.
And then when Connor worked with Mary Kate and looked at this
acrolein signature, which is a mutational signature associated with lipid
aldehydes, okay? What she showed is those patients that had a lot of
fibrosis signature had very significantly elevated
mutations. Okay? So this was kind of compelling.Well,
we wanted to take this one step further and ask, could it
influence risk?
So there are two groups we looked at.
Mammographic density, which has a four-fold increased lifetime risk of
developing breast cancer,
and BRCA mutations, which have a significantly increased
probability of developing breast cancers.
What we showed many years ago, working with Kirk Hansen and Alex
Barrett and people from my group, was that, of course, high mammographic
density has more collagens.
You could see this very clearly, a lot more fibrillar collagen.
And when we did all kinds of measurements with the stiffness, that matrix is
stiffer.
What we know is that there's more macrophage infiltration.
This is not exactly a newsflash. I will say, none of these
mammographically dense tissues had any tumors anywhere in them.
So this is completely normal.
What Mary Kate also saw was there's more DNA damage that she could detect,
and this correlated beautifully and significantly with where the stiffness
was highest in these tissues. And moreover, she sees a lot of
these lipid peroxinitrite-derived aldehydes in these stiffness
regions, in the patients, in these women, they're not patients because they don't
have cancer,
it's higher in these women.
We also recently started working with Radhika Nairan, and we
obtained all these
prophylactic tissues with no cancer with BRCA
patients. And what we see in this case, we were
matching them for high, medium, and low, different kinds of mammographic density.
And even in the high mammographic density patient samples,
or I guess women samples, not patients, what we clearly
were able to detect, this is Radhika, was that they were already stiffer.
Their stroma is really funky.
When she went in, she could show that those tissues are, in fact,
responding to the stiff environment because you find more activated beta-1
integrin, more phospho-myosins, and we could quantify
that. And when Radhika looked a little further,
there's more evidence of phospho-STAT3.
Others have shown that there's an increase in inflammatory infiltrate, and
we can confirm that. So CD68 was much higher, and that we could
detect in these patients. And more importantly, what she
saw was these H&Es were much higher.
There were hotspots of H&Es in these patient samples.
And this correlated very significantly with stiffness.
And this also correlated with little regions where we could
detect DNA damage.
So we now expand our kind of prediction is that
persistent, overwhelming lipid aldehyde-induced oxidative DNA
damage, we believe in part contributed by these myeloid
cells, may eventually exceed nuclear excision repair, and
this leads to accumulated mutations within stiffer regions in the tissue.
And what we're wondering is, could this initiate a transformation in these
high-risk women?
So basically, where we started going with this, and this, of
course, is all unpublished as well, is we've been trying to ask a question is,
what does the stiffness do to chromatin?
And I'm just going to show a few little highlights because this is work that's
ongoing. We've done RNA-seq, ATAC-seq, DamID,
cut-and-run. We have here LAM and B, but we've done it now for a whole
series of methylation marks, et cetera.
And the main sort of observation at this point, but of
course we have more work to do, is that there are some
regions within the
acini-like structures that appear to have the chromatin
that's more accessible. We thought that was kind of cool, and we're following up on
that. One of the things Roger saw was
that the KM2 T2D gene, which is a
lysine-specific methyltransferase, appeared to be in that
region that was more accessible. So we thought that was kind of cool because that's
a region that Mary Kate saw with IG0, was actually
mutated.
What Roger has already seen is that genes like
BRCA1,
some of the beta integrins, MMPs, et cetera, are also
appear to be more accessible in the
breast-like tissues when they're in a stiff environment.
So the way we're thinking about this is that persistent,
overwhelming lipid aldehyde-induced oxidative DNA damage, which is
ongoing, of course it gets repaired, right?
It always gets repaired, but
if you constantly have this load, you can imagine that the nuclear
excision repair capacity may actually be kind
of overwhelmed. It's like a little more possibility of making mistakes.
And we are arguing and looking into the idea that perhaps the
stiffness-induced open chromatin regions that
are actually rendered more accessible in tissues interacting
more with a stiff environment, we think harbor some key tumor
suppressors, and those we believe could get mutated, and
they may contribute to the initiation of transformation in high-risk
women.
I didn't do the work. I'm just the mouthpiece here, and
obviously would be very happy to answer questions.
And again, two ways that you can ask questions, come to the mics
that are on the floor, and the other one is there's the QR code, and I'm supposed
to be able to go and access that in a minute. So...
Hi. That was great. Thank you.
I was wondering if you can elaborate a bit more on what myeloid cells
are producing these ROS, and how are they
being activated by the stiffer environment?
Yeah.
Obviously, I didn't touch on that.
There certainly is some evidence that piezo actually
potentiates... So we know the stiffnessReally cranks up the
lipid aldehyde and the ROS levels in these myeloid cells.
And these myeloid cells are also more pro-tumorigenic.
There
are some earlier papers that suggest that actually
this may be mediated in part through increased piezo, which is a calcium
channel that has been implicated in mechanotransduction.
And second question quickly, do you think this may be playing a
role in aging and the stiffer tissues that happen
through aging, whether for tumor initiation?
That's a very good question. I would be more than happy to talk to people and look
at-- I'm just one small lab,
so yeah. No, it would be very interesting. Absolutely.
Very nice talk. I have two questions.
One is, is it only affecting the ER pathway
or it's also affecting other DNA damage repair pathway?
I'm sure it probably is. We just haven't looked. Okay.
And the inner pathway was the one pathway that really showed
up, and some of the double-strand DNA break kind of
mechanisms for repair looks like those are also affected, but I can only
comment on what we have validated.
Okay. And my second question is, does the stiffness
affect the expression of DNA damage repairs genes?
Good question. I believe that's something that Mary Kate has been
looking at. And yes, some of these genes are induced.
And when we were doing the chromatin analysis accessibility, many of
these DNA repair genes are also rendered more accessible.
So yeah, the tissue is responding, and it's basically
they're turning on a lot of these genes to handle the increased
stress.
Thanks.
Great talk, Val. My question is, when you
show the patient, the people more at risk
of developing
cancer, BRCA and the
high density.
So then you had the plot where you saw the difference, a little
shift. I was wondering, so for those where the
changes were bigger, are actually those that then
actually develop a tumor?
So we have no follow-up data with those individuals.
Oh, okay.
I'm hoping because Christina is here, there's people that have clinical cohorts-
Mm-hmm
... with follow-up.
And we are also collaborating with Joan Brugge's group.
She has, like, 138 patient samples, with BRCA1,
BRCA2. I would say our data did suggest only in
BRCA1, not in BRCA2, which is kind of interesting
because,
earlier at the meeting, one of my colleagues from the
Weizmann suggested that BRCA1 and BRCA2 stroma is
different.
Mm-hmm.
But this is where we need to really-- Because we've done like 20, 30
BRCA tissues and only about 15 BRCA2 and then a bunch of
normals.
So some of the normals are mammary reduction mammoplasty, but others are
prophylactic mastectomy, contralateral breast, et cetera.
So, it's kind of hard. You can't get women to say, "Here, I'll give you a piece of
my breast" if they're not at risk, right?
So,
no, I think we should talk more, but it's certainly
early days in this and we're trying to understand.
We do have a little bit of enticing data that suggests we can
detect in some patients, a very minor group of them, little
regions where we see mutant P53 in what's looking like a
normal breast in the BRCA. We don't know if
those individuals would go on to get cancer because they had a prophylactic
mastectomy, right?
Yeah.
So then they're not going to.
Thank you very much. Thanks.
Well, I think you were before. Yeah.
Thank you so much. Such a great talk.
So the GPX4 phenotype is so strong.
I guess follow-up with the other question, ROS, why is lipid
peroxidation not directing damage?
I mean, ROS does a lot in the cell.
Well, because ROS-- Yeah, ROS can, but-
In terms of stiffness, there's something-
Yeah. The ROS,
it's very short-lived.
Mm.
And it's not going to percolate through the tissue. Okay?
So basically, I'm sure you could have some ROS-mediated
damage, but I'm not sure it actually crosses into the cell.
Mm-hmm.
Whereas we do see that these
lipid aldehyde,
those can.
They're more longer lived. They can actually get into the
cell. They can do all their mischief there.
Whereas ROS is just very, very short-lived.
I see.
I think I'm going to quickly take two questions, then I will be around and I can
answer because we have Dennis Discher that should be coming up now.
All right. Thank you so much for this amazing talk. I'll be very quick.
Tumor mutational burden high tumors are generally considered to respond
better to therapies and have better prognosis.
Now, at the same time,
tumors with a stiff microenvironment have a worse prognosis.
So how do you
bring these two different, I would say, aspects together?
Is it even-
I don't think it's too hard because basically, that's why PARP inhibitors work
really well for BRCA patients, right?
I think you can
imagine a scenario of selection. You can imagine different
mutant cells actually eventually becoming more resistant and coming
out. So you can have both. Both ideas can exist simultaneously,
right?
Triple negatives do much better with immune therapy because they have more immune
infiltrate. But at the same time, if you don't catch them and you aren't able to
really knock it out of the park, those patients end up with metastatic disease.
So there will be evolution of those tumors, and the tumors will-- We
and others have found that they change their metabolic phenotype.
We had a paper, Kevin Tharp is here, where basically they changed
their glycocalyx, which actually impedes the
anti-tumor immunity. So a whole thing is evolving.
So it's not just one thing.
All right, thanks.
Okay, then we need to move on.
Great talk.
Quick question. Do you think a similar
effect will happen on other stiff tissues like bone metastasis
or liver fibrosis or pancreatic cancer?
I don't think this is confined just to breast.
I don't think it's confined only to the primary.
But we haven't looked at it. So I'm not going to rule anything
out. I think there's something very interesting going on here.
We're presenting this here because I'm really hoping all you young
scientists out there, you're going to go do this stuff. I'm the dinosaur here.
My job is to put it out there for people to actually start working on
aging, whatever. Okay?
Beautiful. Thank you.
And then, Dennis.
Basically, I'm going to introduce my colleague from a long time ago at
Penn, Dennis Discher, who's seeing copy number
variation induced by confining
microenvironment
aligned with pan-cancer trends for CNVs.
Okay, thanks so much, Val. That was a terrific talk. Thanks for organizing.
Thanks for staying here.
Slightly different title, but same content.
This is
work done primarily by a postdoc, Alicia Anlas,
with Markus Springer, and some additional contributions from
a new postdoc and former postdoc, Jude and Larry, respectively.
So,
right. So this is sort of the outline.
I'm actually going to jump into the pan-cancer, maybe somewhat related to some of
these last questions. But we're focused on copy number variations.
I will say we've looked at trends that I'll show you with copy number variation
for
insertions, deletions, and they also apply.
So I think there is this sort of pan-cancer story to develop.
And the basic idea is that this is from DNA all the
way to cell matrix. Mechanobiology has the potential indeed, I
think, to feed back into DNA. And for us, it's copy
number variation. So this data on top,
starting with leukemia, is color-coded simply black and white as to whether
white diploid black is a loss or gain.
And so leukemia is sort of well known to have very few copy
number gains and losses, and you're looking at
100 or 200 patients there, whereas the extreme ovarian
cancer,
most of the genome is affected with gains or losses,
whether it's many gains or more than one loss,
we just color code it and then quantify that
in the plot below for the few dozen cancer types in
TCGA,
10,000 patients roughly, plotting against
average transcript levels for collagen I.
And I'll expand on that in the next slide as well.
So leukemia has very low load, very low collagen,
GBM and brain cancer,
a bit more collagen, a bit more copy number variation,
and there's an excellent correlation here.
We've been studying normal tissue stiffness as a function of
collagen protein and collagen transcript.
I show you a little bit of that data collected over many, many years.
And so we really think this collagen, and I think Val's
weaver really supports this, this collagen transcript level is
a pretty good correlate with stiffness of the tissue,
even covering the same range indicated by this hundredfold between
brain and lung.
So,
collagen I really is the most abundant protein and a
major component of a collagen fiber matrisome that
includes, as we just heard about, LOX, MMPs.
It doesn't include cell cycle genes.
KI67
doesn't correlate with CNV. It doesn't correlate with
the collagen fiber matrisome.
There's obviously some matrix genes that also don't
belong to this collagen fiber matrisome.
And it was evident in the data Val showed you, and here we just
repeat from the literature that inhibition of
LOX, for example, which is within the
matrisome with
this inhibitor BAPIN, both decreases stiffness and decreases
collagen fiber intensity. This is a mouse model recently studied.
So our hypothesis became that stiff 3D might
actually induce as opposed to select
for CNV, and so we wanted a simple
experimental model to really try to show this,
really visualize this. And so we want to see
if it's possible that heritable copy number variations
are caused by stiffness.
We're not so much interested in
inducing cell death or arrest, but really
growth with genetic changes, a sort of proper cancer hallmark.
So I tried to identify genes that
are constitutive, where we could do the simplest monoallelic edit
with GFP and RFP.
And
so we identified a few genes on these chromosomes in human cells, and I'll show you
a mouse chromosome 18,
where this monoallelic edit gives us a fluorescent
cell that becomes non-fluorescent as the cell divides,
as that protein is lost, DNA is lostTranscript
is lost, protein is lost, and the snapshots on top
are for RFP lamin B1. It's a protein gene
we've been studying for decades actually, and proves to be a constitutive gene of
this sort.
And you can see, I hope, that initially the box cell, the
box nucleus, is bright and then this dims, whereas
nearby nuclei don't. And as the cell divides, we've got at the
end of this 41-hour movie,
four cells in a colony that have lost, whereas the
lower panel shows GFP H2B is present
throughout.
But also reveals that there are micronuclei, which I'll come back to, and you're
probably aware, are a basis for chromosome loss.
So we can
extract out from any of these culture systems, tissues as well, the
GFP negative cells compared to the GFP positives.
Then we show, in this case, with the H23 lung cancer cells, which I'll focus
on initially, that indeed there's a large fraction of chromosome
5 reproducibly lost.
This approach in visualization, I would argue from all the
evidence I've seen, is much more sensitive than sequencing-based
approaches. And yet, we typically do the
sequencing from single-cell DNA seq, karyotyping,
single-cell RNA seq with InferCNV, SNP arrays
on negatives versus positives. At the bottom is
a recently published study, again, with single-cell RNA seq after we've
confined cells,
and then isolated and enriched for
RFP, in this case, RFP negative cells versus positives.
So I think it's well-validated, but we continue to do this sort of thing.
And here I show our approach to the main hypothesis there
that, well, tumors are 3D, so we're growing
3D spheroids. I'll show you comparison to 2D.
This is that H23 lung cancer cell. It'd been shown a
few years ago by a group at Stanford that this is a
spheroid system that is better at revealing
tumor suppressors and oncogene activity than 2D cultures.
And so what you're seeing here is a couple of cells in the main panel
and five cells in the lower panel forming a colony of GFP negative
cells.
Using liquid viscous methylcellulose, we're able to isolate in many more
spheroids. We again do our profiling and see loss of that
chromosome in the vast majority of cells that we
isolate. But we really want to do this in different
stiffness microenvironments. Agarose is non-adherent, so we're really able to focus
on stiffness.
The table there quantifies, on average
across 20 or so spheroids,
the number of cells where we see the reporter loss, as we call it,
number of colonies on average. The sum of those
is the mutational events on average.
You divide by the number of cells corrected for the initial seeding, and that
gives you a mutation rate per division.
So really reducing it to numbers. And we quantify that
from the liquid methylcellulose, the open circle in this main plot,
to the stiffest agarose, which is about 30 kilopascal at 3%
agarose. And that's a tenfold increase in mutation rate
due to stiffness. What's also interesting, and reproduces decades of
work from others, is as you stiffen up the
microenvironment, growth is suppressed.
So we're getting a suppression of growth with more mistakes
per division.
There's another way to look at this.
So Luria and Delbrück were really the first to quantify mutation rates
and understand variance. And so we look at this
just by, is the spheroid showing a mutation or not?
And this so-called method of zeros provides an underestimate and,
instead of tenfold, we see sixfold by this method, but otherwise very similar
trend as a function of stiffness. They importantly, for
their Nobel Prize years ago, told us that the variance, this
is a very non-Gaussian, non-Poisson process, and the variance over the
mean relates to that sort of mutation rate, variation rate,
times the number of cells. And so that's what we plot here, the
ratio versus the mean. And it sort of fits the ideas
I've put out there that the variation is really super
Poisson, as we expect, but trails off at high
stiffness because proliferation is being suppressed.
Compared to 2D, we see more mutations, especially more mutations
per division than we ever see in
3D, more so than we see in 2D. I'll come to sort of
mechanisms and tell you right now, cells like this round up off of the
plastic field or microenvironment much less, but really
confinement is what's going on here.
So that was flow cytometry result with tens of thousands of
cells, really quantitative. We don't see colonies, so we can't correct
for mutation causing a colony, but we reproduce
that with mouse cells, B16 melanoma, which allow us
to go in vivo, as I'll show you next.
And we get the same trend, that 3D is
more disruptive than 2D, but likewise, a stiff
matrix surrounding the spheroids, these B16 spheroids,
increases, well, here it's sevenfold, which is close to the
six to tenfold range I showed you for the human cells.
So indeed, we implanted this. This is in immunocompetent
mice.
The melanoma tumor itself is
soft.Sort of neuronal, neuroepithelial, if you will, type
lineage. But then with time, collagen accumulates at the
boundary analogous, I want to say, to the agro
stiffness that we study in vitro. And so we see a
progressive stiffening at the periphery
that doesn't occur at the core over time.
When we use, of course, our Cre reporter cells, 2D
cultures have a long-term limit in these studies of
just a very small fraction, 0.26%, showing Cre
reporter loss, and this increases fairly rapidly in a week or two,
after many divisions, of course, though, in vivo, by several fold.
So qualitatively at least, semi-quantitatively, consistent with what
I showed you, and we could even estimate from the mutational burden that this is a
modestly stiff,
somewhat soft, but
not super
stiff type tumor.
So let me return to a concept or two that arose in the
experimental data I just showed you.
So I started by just showing you copy number gains and
losses trending with collagen. Does this really apply to just loss of
chromosomes?
And indeed, it does. I showed you data for human
chromosome five loss and the heat map here for all the
chromosomes and all the cancers just aligns statistically
very well with collagen concentrations, as did CNV,
as does LOH. LOI also is
correlated. So it almost doesn't matter what chromosome you
look at. LOH 17 is important because that's
the most
common frequent loss in cancer. P53 is on
chromosome 17, and it tracks with this. It follows this trend as well.
And this is one particular cancer paper that caught our
eye that indicates chromosome losses occur
before gains. And so mutations occur first in these
colorectal
cancers and P53, APC, these are
suppressors that are lost and help driving the cancer together with KRAS.
But you can have those mutations, I think it's clear from this meeting, a lot of
sequencing that's going on, have these mutations in the absence of any cancer.
I'm not sure that's true as
copy number variation takes off here, but losses are
preceding gains. And so we've looked at that,
as I'll show you in a few slides. But let me just say ovarian
cancer has somewhat of a similar story.
You have P53 mutations. This is
data from my colleague at Penn, Ronnie Dreapkin, who's
provided some support for this work.
And so he points out you can have these P53 signatures and DNA
damage, but no sign of cancer until maybe 20 years later
in the fallopian tube epithelial cells.
And then as that becomes truly cancerous and
invasive, 3D and more and more collagen,
CNVs take off, consistent with an ovarian cancer having this high
CNV and stiffness. I'll just point out, I
emphasize averages so far, but there's tons of single-cell
data to look at that's at least a small
snapshot of what's going on in the cancer, and you'll see sort of
low percentage variations, even with what's being flagged and
called a clone, and this matters in terms of tumor evolution, where
one clone is taken over by another or taken over by another, whether it's
under therapy or not.
So I'll show you some of the cell biological, biophysical
mechanisms we think contribute. So in our first study with these Cre reporters,
we took our human cells and planted xenografts in mice,
showed that the mitotic cells are seemingly squashed.
They're not rising to the height that you'd see in vitro,
typically with these cells rounding up as they divide, and I'm talking
about the chromatin mass. And so we mimic that by squashing
the cells, preventing them from rounding up, following
Tim Mitchison and Sophie Dumont, and others
since. And we mimic that and then went on to show in this
paper a few years ago that this leads to the Cre reporter loss.
But more recently, tuned the height of our confinement
to try to really get at, is it mitosis truly or that's being
disrupted or maybe interphase nuclear rupture?
Now, this doesn't have the macrophages that we just heard about, but it's out
there for a number of years that interphase cells in
confined environments have nuclear rupture and DNA damage.
And so we did confirm that when we strongly confined cells,
interphase cells, we see the nuclear rupture.
At 10 micron, there's no nuclear rupture, but there is compression of
the mitotic cells. And
the mitotic cells that are compressed by the 10
micron or 2 micron, those are the ones that seem most important that
our Cre reporter loss is statistically the same
under all these conditions. So it's really from this sort of data, the
mitotic cells that are contributing to the reporter
loss. So indeed, as we jump back into our spheroids,
we see that
on the surface of a spheroid grown in liquid, the cells are able to round
up, whereas in the core, they're not.
The mitotic cells are not able to push the
nearby cells out of the way,
and this is at the surface also affected by the
surrounding agarose,
suppressing even the rounding on the surface.
It propagates into the cell. The spindles are compressed, not just the mitotic
cells. And this,
given what I just showed you with confinement of cells, leads to predictions that
this contributes to Cre reporter loss, but I'll flesh that
out.So,
we knocked down myosin II as a major player in rounding of cells,
and the yellow arrow there points to a cell on the surface in a
stiff agarose gel, and it's simply unable to round up into the media.
Too stiff of a gel without the myosin II.
And that's the condition we can actually map out where the mutations are arising,
so to speak, where the reporters are lost.
And that's the surface in the stiff gel with
myosin II knockdown is the maximum reporter loss per division that
we see. But there is enhancement in the core as well, so the cells are
using myosin II in the core to create
space. Knocking it down leads to more mistakes.
This, I think, aligns with
screen results that Elaine Fuchs reported about a dozen years
ago, knocking down a whole bunch of genes and reporting that myosin II is a tumor
suppressor. You knock it down and you end up with cancer.
She didn't really get into genomic mechanisms that we're suggesting here, but
maybe copy number variation is one of them.
So I come back to micronuclei that we see more often, more
abundant in the core
than on the surface, and more so in
spheroids grown in stiff gel conditions.
So, micronuclei arise from missegregation of chromosomes.
Here, showing some data, a summary or review from Don
Cleveland here in San Diego and Peter Lee, former postdoc.
When the missegregation occurs in the sort of simplest view
of generating micronuclei, one daughter cell has immediate
loss. Given what I showed you before, that seems reasonable.
But the other daughter cell has this micronuclei that can become a gain,
although DNA damage, rupture of the micronucleus, failure to integrate
are some of the possible fates. But it prompted us to look more
carefully for
lost colonies next to gains or vice versa.
And indeed, we see smaller gain colonies in general, consistent with the
sort of model of a delay, consistent with what I showed you, at least for
colorectal cancer. Hence our focus on losses, I think, is justified.
But it also, with data like that, with a view of
instability like that, prompted us to use drugs like reversine that
inhibits the spindle assembly checkpoint in 2D. This works well.
Many have shown. You increase micronuclei.
This leads to increase, in our case, reporter loss.
But in 3D, it doesn't happen.
You increase reporter loss to the same extent we see in 3D,
and adding that drug has no additional effect.
However, what we do see is mitosis in 3D in these spheroids
is taking longer, and that's more aligned with not inhibitors
like with reversine, which accelerates mitosis, but
nocodazole. Low dose nocodazole or nocodazole washout experiments
prolong mitosis.
I can also say that we don't see more DNA damage in
our spheroids, even with the reversine drug.
But what I've told you so far, and could add, is that our
data is aligning with a mitotic delay
and a spindle perturbation that you achieve in 2D with nocodazole or with
confinement
or in our spheroids. Perturbing the spindle, nocodazole also
mechanically, physically shortens the spindle and also generates
micronuclei, delays cell cycle, but leads to the same level of
reporter loss that I show you with our spheroids and confinement.
It's understood in that context that cohesion fatigue is a major player, so we
knock down
one of these factors, WAPL,
in that pathway. It suppresses missegregation
and
suppresses, rescues partially, the reporter loss.
So I think we provide some data here for this pathway.
I'll finish with how this may play out in looking
at survival. We need to do more in CNV analysis, but it basically says
if you look at the combination, myosin II and collagen I, it should
relate to survival, and it's generally true across all cancers here.
These are our conclusions. Pan-cancer copy number variation and losses,
more specifically, no doubt gains, increase with collagen I, not with cell
cycle. Heritable chromosome loss rate increases tenfold from soft
to stiff.
3D stiff cell biomechanisms, biophysical, biological mechanisms,
involve distorted and prolonged mitosis that phenocopies effects of
drugs like low dose nocodazole in 2D cultures.
So with that, I'll be happy to take any questions if there's time.
So please use the mics, and also you can type your
questions into... And then I'll read them out to
Dennis.
Great talk. Thank you very much for bringing this topic.
So collagen I and
copy number gain or loss are very
highly expressed or highly observed in sarcomas.
Yeah.
And such as aggressive osteosarcomas or
vascular cancers, but those
types of cancers are very rare. And
because your hypothesis is that the stiffness
impacts on copy number change, but these
sarcomas are very rare, but they have a high level
of chromosome rearrangements. And what do you think about
this at the tissue level or the macro level
of a stiffness?
So our studies here are with cancer
cells, so these are already cancer cells.
And I think you're trying to ask
is this driving the initiation?
Right. Yeah.
As opposed to... So I'm still a big believer that you need
p53 and APC, some of these tumor suppressor mutations and
oncogenes first.Right? So I don't
know what's going on in sarcomas with respect to that, but
those then allow
the CNVs to then take off. And
when we've worked, at least in confinement with
normal cells,
just iPS as a model, which you can argue, push back.
We can drive these losses and gains, but the cells die.
They don't have, arguably, the guardian, the p53
defects and this sort of thing, and so they go down
death and arrest rather than heritable chromosome
losses
that we associate with, whether it's p53 or other
pathways that allow it.
Yeah. That's great. Thank you very much.
Yeah.
This is very interesting.
Thank you.
Are there any other... Oh, looks like there's one more.
Just one quick question. Do you have any idea where these CNVs are located?
Could it be that they are extrachromosomal?
I think that's a general question in the CNV space, right?
You see tumors with large copy number variations of genes,
and because much of it is detected through sequencing, you don't know actually
where they're physically located.
So I was wondering whether they might actually be extrachromosomal, which would
also explain why tumors with high CNVs-
No. So other than one slide I showed you, everything was losses.
Right?
Okay.
So experimentally, and then I showed
you TCGA data for losses that aligns with this
hypothesis. But
extrachromosomal DNA would, to my knowledge, really only give you
gains. And
yeah.
That's correct. Yeah.
I was talking to someone at the meeting, they said, "You should look for copy in
TCGA, copy number variation that's above seven." That's
the opposite direction of much of our story, but it is a direction we're headed.
So it's a really good question looking forward. But, yeah.
So you haven't seen much of gains in other tumor types or-
We're just-
Okay
... getting into gains now because they come later, like I
say. We see that experimentally. We see that to some extent that's
in the literature. And
you raise a good point because sequencing doesn't give you that
temporal usually, unless you work very hard. Right?
Thank you.
Yeah.
That was very...
Thanks.
There's a question here.
Oh.
You can answer that. The bottom one.
Okay. Just do it online.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Our last speaker, last but not least, she's a
powerhouse.
I'm flattered that she agreed to speak in this
session. I'm pulling her unwittingly
into the mechano field. So Christina Curtis from Stanford.
She's going to talk about evolution under pressure, spatial mechanical
niches in breast cancer. So take her away, Christine.
Is it okay?
Yeah.
Yeah, let's do it.
Yeah, this has been a fantastic session.
I'm so glad to hear these diverse perspectives on how we can really bring it all
together, and I will, as well said, feel like
I'm just entering into the point of having some data that might
possibly speak to this, and we hope to do a lot more, so really looking forward to
the feedback.
These are my disclosures.
No, I answered that one.
Not relevant to the talk today.
Yes.
So my lab has had a longstanding interest in understanding how tumors
evolve through space and time. Much of our
work has focused on tumor evolution, and in fact, we're huge believers
that genomic instability and copy number variation drives much of this.
But to put this in tissue context, we of course, need to sample disease throughout
its course. And, I'll focus on breast cancer today, though we also do
quite a bit of work in these other genome unstable tumors such as osteosarcoma.
If we want to do this, however, our view is that we actually have to study
tissues across multiple scales. Really understanding
cell-cell interactions both in 2D and 3D, and of course, in native
tissue context.
We need to understand how those interactions feed up into microenvironmental
context, and then really, we have to do this at a tissue level.
And I'll say, as a computational scientist, a huge part of our
goal is actually to make these measurements across spatial scales so
we can model them in silico, so we can build virtual tissue models of
disease. And I say this just because we never have ground truth.
So those simulations, if we embed this very rich information, can become
incredibly powerful. But before we can do that, we actually have to have the data,
which is what we have embarked on. So, what I'll speak to
you about today is really how we're looking at
measuring these different modalities,
ranging from digital pathology. I don't want to leave that behind.
I gave a talk on some generative AI approaches for digital path and how we can even
predict molecular features from that yesterday, and there's a wonderful preprint
you can read about. Today, I'll focus instead on how we're using these other
modalities to learn about tissues in context.
So I want to start and just highlight some of the past work that
we and others have done using spatial proteomics, because I think it actually shows
very powerfully how important these niches are.
And I hope it also convinces you that even when we don't have the full tissue
section, because that is not clinically feasible, we learn quite a bit.
So, very briefly, we've conducted a number of
studies with wonderful clinician scientists, looking
at repeat sampling throughout either targeted therapy, in this case, in the
context of anti-HER2, in this TRIO-USB07 study.
And in this study, we had a pre-treatment biopsy and on-treatment biopsy without
chemo, which is really remarkable. It was just trastuzumab.
And then we were monitoring patients for whether they achieved a pathologic
complete response, if the tumor went away.
And, I won't dwell on this. You can read about it.
It was work we did some time ago. We just used regional spatial proteomics,
not even single-cell. And we looked on treatment, and we learned that we could
predict based on the delta in protein changes, which patients would
achieve a pCR.We reduced that to a very simple digital pathology
assay, and we're now validating it in a completed Phase 3 trial with a view that we
can potentially spare women unnecessary chemo.
So this was our first hope that even though we only had core biopsies, we could
learn something.
And more recently, in work that was just published a few months ago,
we did something similar but with higher resolution technology in the tonic
trial. This was looking at anti-PD-1 in metastatic triple-negative breast cancer.
We had multiple biopsies throughout the treatment course, and we did single-cell
spatial proteomics. And so I'll just briefly say, this was a pretty remarkable
longitudinal dataset where not only do we have the primary
tumors, but we have the baseline pre-treatment with nivo
and then on nivo. And
we collected a variety of modalities.
Of course, we studied the TME, as I mentioned, with 37plex MIBI
spatial proteomics. We also did RNA sequencing, whole exome sequencing,
and you can start to imagine that we can compare static features as well
as dynamic features in the TME and ask, what predicts response to
nivo, since we know it's only a subset of patients that benefit.
And I'll cut to the chase and just say one of the key findings observed from this
is that spatial niches really matter, even in these tiny biopsies.
So actually here, the diversity at the
cancer border. We've segmented out the populations of cells, we've
labeled them, as you can see here. So the cell diversity at
the neighborhood of the surrounding tumor actually
predicts response. And you can see this for patient 64, which is highlighted right
here. So I think this tells us that spatial
topography tells us quite a bit about who's going to achieve a
response. And I'll just say furthermore, that actually studying
tumors throughout disease tells us that different features are predictive at
different times. So maybe not surprisingly, if you look at the many
hundreds of features we can compute from these spatial proteomic data, there's a
lot more that are predictive at the on-nivo time point.
And we could have a whole debate about which features we need, but
you might be also surprised to see that in this analysis, the RNA is as
predictive as the protein in determining response.
Arguably, mechanistically, we can learn more from the spatial proteomics, but I
just want to say there's a lot to contemplate if we're going to actually make
longitudinal measurements of disease.
So, this leads me to say that that was really a focus on
understanding how we can measure response to therapy
through spatial efforts. And over the many years, we've helped
to delineate new subgroups of breast cancer.
I want to stress that we've known for a long time there are some 14, 15% of breast
cancers that are HER2 positive. But amongst the 80% of estrogen
receptor positive tumors, we've defined some eight subgroups.
Four of those have an exceptionally high risk of relapse.
Their risk is in excess of 55% for two decades.
You can see these women that are ER positive high risk in orange do as poor as
women with HER2 positive disease before the routine use of trastuzumab.
We still don't optimally treat these women.
They are very, very different than their typical risk counterparts in blue.
And what's special about them is that they have focal copy number amplifications,
much like HER2, but at different loci throughout the genome.
17q23 is integrative cluster one.
This 8p12 amplification, which spans FGFR1, defines
another nearly 6% of these tumors, and so forth.
And we've characterized these ad nauseam.
We've mapped their structural variant landscape.
They are wildly rearranged in a focal manner.
And so we know that copy number is playing a key role in driving their disease
progression. Now, we've also shown, intriguingly, that these
women that have HER2 positive disease, as well as those with estrogen receptor
positive disease that are high risk, shown here in this orange color, are heavily
immune depleted. Not exclusively.
You can see some are more fibrotic, some are immune and rich non-fibrotic, but
compared to, let's say, the typical risk tumors down
here or triple negative, they're immune depleted.
And what's intriguing is, I won't show it here, but you could read about it in this
publication. If you map these patients at a genome-wide level
using whole genome sequencing and reconstruct their
maps without labeling what subtype they are, we actually couldn't really
distinguish HER2 positive from ER positive high risk.
What distinguishes them is their focal copy number alterations and where those
reside. So these tumors are very similar.
And this led us to the question, well, these patients that have high-risk ER
positive disease are immune depleted, but what do we know about their
microenvironments beyond what we can infer from bulk data?
So this leads me to really an area I want to focus on, which is we know that
these women have very high risk. We know that their genome is determinant.
We can predict that risk for two decades.
But what might the microenvironment tell us about these patients as well?
So we embarked on a study. This is the first set of patients that we
profiled. We have roughly 336 women with ER
positive HER2 negative disease for whom we have 20 years of clinical follow-up.
We put them on a tissue microarray, and we use the CosMX,
used to be NanoString, now Bruker platform, to profile them at either 1,000 plex
or 6,000 plex, looking at that many transcripts.
With this, we can do a number of things.
We can define cell types, we can define cellular niches, we can look at cell-cell
interactions, and we can do all the kinds of things that I told you about with
protein, looking at diversity, densities, and ratios.
There are thousands of metrics we can compute from these spatial data.
But our goal was really to ask, can we create this kind of integrated tumor
ecosystem?
Now, this is just to reassure you that across these several hundred
patients, we can really map out the major cell type populations from these spatial
data. You'll see pretty good representation of myeloid cells.
Pretty striking depletion of lymphoid, but we can also pick a number of
different stromal compartments.
And again, we can do a very deep dive into all these
different patterns of cell-cell communication and colocalization.
So what do we learn when we start to parse these data?
Well, the first thing we can do is ask, what's the interaction or the type of
colocalization between source cells and target cells?And
I hope you can see that there's quite a lot of groupings along this diagonal.
We're essentially looking at the co-localization patterns of certain cell types.
And maybe you can also notice that we can map these onto
different types of niches. So we're going to say we have these eight niches over
here, and this one happens to be pretty dramatically enriched for
cancer cells. So it turns out this niche zero is very dense in cancer
cells.
Something like 60% beyond of the cells in this population
are just cancer epithelium. And that's pretty different than some of these other
groups. You could argue maybe niche two also has a good representation of the
epithelium. Now, I want to focus on this niche because the
point here is we're trying to study at various levels of resolution what's
happening in the microenvironment.
And so the first very simple question we had is: How does that pertain to outcome
in this patient cohort where we have 20 years of follow-up?
And lo and behold, you can pretty nicely see that patients that have
this increased density of cancer cells are, in fact, statistically
significantly enriched for those who relapse.
This is different than most of the other niches that we defined.
And so you might say, "Well, that's actually quite boring.
They have more cancer cells. You've just told me that they're enriched
for a lot of densely packed cells." So, this was our
first thought, but we thought maybe we should investigate this further.
So I just want to show you that actually just looking at niche stratification,
we see this pretty dramatic separation in patient outcomes.
So these are patients that have niche zero.
They have very poor prognosis. But what's exciting
is that I previously told you we could predict 20 years risk of relapse from our
integrative subtypes.
What we see now is that determination of the microenvironment
layers on top of what we had defined previously based on the genome alone,
and these patients that are ER-positive, typical risk, but niche zero
high have a pretty poor prognosis. We might have misclassified them.
We might have thought that they would do better.
They are not, in fact, typical risk. They're doing far worse.
So what this means, and we can show it in a multivariate Cox proportional hazard
analysis, is that in fact, layering on TMA information improves the
stratification of genomic classifiers.
This is the first time we've really been able to demonstrate this.
So I can come back to the co-localization that I showed you.
There's these different groupings of cancer epithelial cells.
You might notice, if you can squint, that in green, we also have this pretty
dramatic co-localization of perivascular-like cells.
And in fact, the fibroblasts, endothelial cells, and perivascular-like
cells are all clustering. And this is really telling us that these
groups of cells are interacting more than we would expect by
chance.
And you can, in fact, see that the fibroblasts are behaving in a somewhat similar
fashion, and that this is associated with relapse risk.
So now we're observing an additional pattern of
co-localization. It turns out that this is all happening in niche
zero. So niche zero is not so boring after all, because in fact,
what we're really observing is that there's a dramatic enrichment of
perivascular-like cells co-localizing with fibroblasts, and that's happening
just in that tumor-dense niche.
So clearly, there's something going on here, and we can show that
this is associated with relapse. And you might ask, "Well, what else is happening?"
We can now start to zoom in on this. This is a patient that didn't relapse, and you
can see a very different topography of the fibroblasts and
perivascular-like cells. In contrast, in these two patients, patient
three and two, who relapsed, you see really this
enrichment of fibroblasts within this densely packed set of cancer cells.
And we see this time and time again.
So they have fundamentally different topographies.
And, in fact, we can show that not only is this enriched in those
patients that relapse, it's enriched in the lymph node metastases
and to a subtle degree in distant mets.
These are unpaired distant metastases.
So we see them
in the patients that recur, and we see them in their metastases.
And I don't have time to go into all of the data that underlies this, so I just
want to summarize to say that what we think is happening is that there are collagen
1A1 positive E-cadherins that are essentially helping to set up the
structural ECM. We see co-option of a number of integrins, and
we believe that we're laying down this basement membrane that
promotes vessel stabilization in the
absence of VEGF signaling. And this becomes quite interesting because, as many
of you will know, we have a whole new class of bispecific VEGF inhibitors that are
coming of age. And we think that this may be independent of VEGF,
that there's stabilization really promoted by the ECM,
and that this may permit tumor perfusion.
So there's much more to be said about this, but
the reason I illustrate this one vignette is to say there's so much more we can
learn when we have this resolution of data and 1,000 or
6,000 transcripts to start to understand how cells
are interacting within the ECM.
Now, I cut this short so that I could move on and talk about a few other features
of the data. And our goal ultimately is to integrate
all of this, but I'm going to show you some data that's literally fresh off the
press because
this is, after all, a mechanobiology session that I was co-opted
into.
So in literally very recent work and analyses led by
Brendan Simon, who's sitting over in the room, this was a collaboration with
Richard Drake, Peggy Angel, and Mike Angelo.
We've been performing a spatial glycomics and collagen profiling via multi-mass
spec on those same sets of TMAs. We've in fact now done 1,000 breast
tumors in total. And so you can start to see the peak matrix that emerges from
this. I want to just point out that this resolution is different than the
single-cell spatial transcriptomics.
It's actually 40-micrometer spatial resolution.
So that brings us down to some tricks that we need when we start to co-localize the
data. But we can get maps of about 172 glycan channels and
161 collagen channels from these data across the
TMAs.So one of the first things that we were interested in
is coming back to our tumor-dense regions, which by the way, we have these digital
pathology methods. We can pick them up pretty robustly.
And you can start to see that in the cancer regions, we see an enrichment of
COL6A1, COL3A1, COL1A2, we heard about that
earlier, and others. And these are specifically found, as you can see
here, enriched in the tumor-dense regions, far less so in those that are less
dense. And so with this data, once again, you have an embarrassment of
riches in analyses you can perform.
But one of the types of approaches we do is to look at hotspots.
How do these spatial features relate to one another?
How do they co-localize? And, I'll just call your attention to
this module four over here,
which you can see down at the bottom.
So you sort of see there's a pretty dramatic difference between these.
These seem to show an enrichment amongst non-relapsing
patient tumors, where we see module four is upregulated.
And I just want to stress that this analysis is based on just a small subset of
TMAs from that full cohort. That's all we have so far.
But we're already seeing some interesting associations with relapse, and we can now
dig into what those modules are. And one of the first things we see is that there's
differential enrichment of both fibroblasts as well as
SPP1 macrophages. In this case, we see a differential
enrichment of SPP1,
versus SPP1-positive Macs in this population that is not relapsing.
Those patterns tend to change in module nine, we see a dramatic enrichment of
plasma cells and perivascular-like cells,
and collagen VI has a different set of patterns.
But we're very interested now in mining these data and trying to understand
how collagen structure is relating to the distinct topography
of the spatial transcriptomic interactions we defined.
So we have many modalities, not enough time to talk about all of them, so I'll move
quickly on from that. One of the key tasks here, as you might imagine, is to now
take all these tissue microarray cores where we've got multiple
modalities, and to coregister them.
So for the RNA and the protein, we have single-cell resolution.
In fact, we can get to subcellular.
But as I said, this is not the case for the glycan and collagen.
So we have to basically parse these out into 100 micron by 100 micron
regions, pursue coregistration, and we can then start to look for
different neighborhoods. There's many ways you can integrate these data,
and we could talk about that offline.
I think one of the approaches that we tend to use is graph-based coregistration
algorithms. We can start to merge all these data.
And I'm not talking about the H&Es, but this is the backbone, because of course, we
have very precise morphology derived from the H&E
images. So now we can start to look at the single-cell densities and how
well-preserved they are across these different levels.
In fact, we can see that our coregistration is looking pretty good.
So you can just zoom in on these different quadrants.
I hope you can appreciate that there's many cell types that we
represent from the single-cell transcriptomics. They're documented over here.
You saw them on that first map that I showed you.
But now we can also coregister this with, let's say, pan cytokeratin levels
measured at the protein level, or indeed CD45 quantifying lymphocytes.
And Brennan put together this nice video that hopefully
plays. Yes. So we'll just walk through a few of these
examples where you can see if you really want to drill into any
of these markers, we can start to see how they correlate or don't, and sort of
the density of information we get back from this.
And so I think this is just our first view of, okay, coregistration seems to work,
and now we can start to see how we can combine with the glycan signals that
we're observing alongside the single-cell measurements.
And
hopefully, you can appreciate that there's some patterns emerging there.
This was just from one single core on the tissue
microarray. And
with this, and even in this just very first-pass analysis,
we can start to appreciate that there are different glycan neighborhoods that are
also emerging. So here in green, we have neighborhood
six. This seems to be upregulated for a number of
glycans. In contrast, we see this neighborhood four down here, where we actually
see
a negative enrichment. So we are observing that across a
different TMA core, we can start to see these patterns.
And of course, our ongoing goal is to parse what those really look like.
And just in the last few minutes, wanted to share really recent work with
Val's lab, and thanks to Radhika, who labored and
toiled to get these very rapidly. But we were excited to share the exact same
tissue microarrays that I just showed you.
And so, you already heard from the beautiful work from Val
about how they use atomic force microscopy and actually have a really powerful
convolutional neural network to start to map out stiffness.
And this stiff map can then be deployed on the
same TMAs we've generated. And what you can see here, and this is just the first
TMA that we profiled, all that we've had time to do, that there's
indeed an association with stiffness and those patients that relapse after two
decades. And if we further stratify into the top 20% stiffness
values, we indeed see a pretty dramatic enrichment.
So this is fresh off the press, literally.
I think we got the data three days ago.
So we are now deep in the weeds of trying to relate the
very beautiful images that are derived from that back onto our collagen and
glycome information. And we hope that with this, we'll be able to
really start to ask the question: how well do these modalities correlate?
What do they tell us about the microenvironment in ways that we've never been able
to quantify? And, a big part of the ongoing work in my
lab is really to focus on how we can curate and integrate these
data. Of course, there's a huge amount of machine learning behind the scenes that
allows us to do this. But what Brennan's also working towards is agentic
deployment framework, so that we can have AI agents operating over these data and
allowing us to really make new predictions about the putative biomarkers.
Because we may have in our minds a number of biomarkers that we think are relevant.
I have dozens that I want to test. But now with the scale of data and the
number of possible comparisons we can make, we actually want to automate this,
and eventually to make this a tool that can be deployed by the community.
So-I'll just close by saying that we think that we can
find spatial features that predict relapse in the TME.
We're seeing these very powerful ECM-driven vascular
niches, and we believe that they're bypassing VEGF signaling.
Didn't have time to get into the experimental data supporting that.
And now that we're also seeing that collagen correlates with relapse,
and stiff map profiling does, we have a lot of work to do to understand, are
these just collective signals that we're essentially measuring from the data?
So our ongoing work will integrate this.
I want to thank the amazing team, especially Brennan and Lise, who led
much of this work, our wonderful collaborators with whom we've generated these
data, and the patient advocates who constantly remind us that it
is, to what Val said in the beginning, really important that we take these powerful
technologies and relate them to patient outcomes so that we can understand what we
need to measure to better prognosticate.
I'm just going to make one more plug that
I and others are chairing
the second Data Science Conference.
This will be held in March 2027 up in San
Francisco, and we think a huge focus of that meeting will be on spatial and
hopefully mechanobiology. So hopefully, mark your calendars and join us.
Thank you.
So the session is now open for questions.
Kindly go to the mics, and also you can go online
using the QR code.
Very nice talk. Thank you very much.
I have a question about collagen mapping.
So there is a very traditional method for collagen staining, such as
trichrome staining on the tissues.
What's the difference between this kind of
traditional staining and the newer methods?
Here, we're using a mass spec readout of the actual peaks.
So, I'm not sure if I can go backwards.
No, I'm wondering what's the readouts and what's the benefit of using
your technology at lower resolution of...
Our goal here is to be able to map these in spatial resolution in relation to
the other features, and of course, to discover the full
spectrum of collagens that can be related to it.
So I think we're willing to sort of sacrifice the trade-off in
resolution. There are, of course, ever-increasing methods to get down to
lower resolution. But as I hope I showed you in relation to our
observations with respect to relapse, we're seeing it doesn't, to some degree
matter whether we're looking at this in a neighborhood of cells or otherwise.
We still see that association. So,
there's a breadth question, and then there's a sort of
depth question about how you want to profile tissue, and for us, it's really
about being able to relate it to the other features.
But we can certainly chat more offline, or Dennis, if you want to.
All right. Great. Thank you very much.
Christina, great talk.
Thanks, Lily.
Lily Gunther from St. Jude. I have a question about your spatial
transcriptomics part and the niche zero, and I was
really interested in that wall of cancer
epithelium. And we think in osteosarcoma, another disease
you think about a little bit about this, what makes up
that wall from a cancer epithelium standpoint, and whether or not those
cells are different than the rest of them.
And I was wondering if you've started to get into that with your spatial data.
Can you see a different cell state or anything about those cells that
sort of exclude the microenvironmental cells?
Yeah. So I had to take all of that out to fit in more data.
We have done a lot with the spatial transcriptomics.
One thing I can say is that there's definitely interactions
at the level of, for example, receptor ligand interactions with
the surrounding microenvironment.
Not surprisingly, we see much of what others have shown
with respect to SPP1 positive macrophages that are surrounding
there. We think that what we really want to understand is what is driving
the sort of immune suppressive environment that we observe with these myeloid
cells. At the same point, there are structural changes that we also observe
and a lot of crosstalk there. So one of the ways that we're trying
to parse that, and it's a simplistic route, but because we've also
established patient-derived organoid models of disease, and we heard about
the importance of 3D, we can go back in those models, imperfect though
they may be, and try to reconstitute some of those
two-way, maybe up to three-way interactions.
Mm-hmm.
And indeed, we're able to corroborate some of the predictions that are made from
the patient data. So our view is let's start with the patient data and go back and
try to perturb this.
Okay.
And I say this because, of course, everything we see in the tissue is correlative.
Yeah.
It's not causation, and the big challenge we have for a lot of
these is how do we then perturb that-
Interconvert to something better
... en masse. Right.
Yeah.
And there's other tools. There's organ-on-a-chip type models.
We could obviously go in vivo. Unfortunately, in vivo for ER positive disease is
not a great system either.
Yeah.
But there are things happening at that border that I think
really matter, and it isn't just the density of cancer cells.
Mm-hmm.
And what I didn't say here, but we have looked carefully at, and I think this is
where the digital pathology approaches help, is if you had a whole slide image and
you looked across it, we would see different regions of that density.
Mm.
And so the reason I showed those examples from clinical trials in the beginning is
those are all core biopsies.
Yeah.
And we had to convince ourselves that sampling a little core biopsy, maybe two
passes through the needle, could still tell us about response.
And so I'm sort of convinced that even though we're not capturing the whole tissue,
we see that. But boy, it kind of alarms me when I look at the whole slide images
and you see the degree of heterogeneity there. It's pretty vast.
So we
have to be aware of what we're sampling and heterogeneity throughout, both at a
genomic and microenvironmental level.
Yeah. Absolutely. Thanks.
Thank you.
Fabulous talk and really excellent entire session.
Pepper Shedeen from OHSU. So, Christina, thank you so much for that.
When you see some of your images, which are from really dense data
sets, you evoke
tumor differentiation state, your denseepithelial
area versus your non-dense look like differentiated
versus non-differentiated.
And so my question is, can you start to overlay what's known about the
pathology of disease, which is not
rigorous enough to really predict at the individual level, but to
overlay that onto your data sets to
advance the field?
Yeah.
And not leave behind
grade of tumor. Can you see different grades?
Yeah. I wish I had a bit more time. I would've combined that.
So one of the things that we're using these very powerful digital pathology tools
is to basically have these
quantitative estimates of what we observe across the tissue, from the
tile level down to the individual pixel level.
And we're learning a lot of biology from these methods.
Now, some of the generative AI methods let us actually get towards, I
think the way we're viewing it is we can sort of get to its mechanistic
interpretability by asking, what's the transition, let's say, from a high risk to a
typical risk lesion? And a lot of that follows what we know about grading,
staging, pathology. We don't want to omit that information.
Right.
It's so rich.
So
what I would stress, the reason I showed the H&E at the fore, although I didn't
talk about is, without that grounding, I think we could be misleading ourselves.
And we will also really struggle to scale any of these tools at a population level.
So one of our big tasks is now we can make measurements on FFP tissue
at scale in clinical samples. But how much could we predict from an
H&E? And I think we can predict some spatial transcriptomic features and proteomic.
I'm not convinced we're that good at predicting glycans.
I don't know that we will get there. We have to ask about the rest of the data.
We're just gathering it to do it. But the view would be to be integrated
and not to overlook what's known about the pathology, for sure. Thank you.
And I have a second question.
Yeah.
Which is, you surprised me by saying that you did the
proteomics, and then you did some subset of
RNA sequencing, and the RNA was, you didn't
need the proteomics, which kind of is at the antithesis of
all of this, we need more.
That's why I said it. That's provocative, yes.
Yeah. It's very provocative.
Yeah, so that was just to make the point that we were asking could we
predict response to nivo in a-
Yeah, that's right
... phase two trial? And the answer there was that, in that
on-treatment biopsy, the RNA was every bit as predictive as the protein.
But if I were to go back at an earlier time point, that probably wasn't the case.
So it's time point dependent.
And I would still say it depends on your goal.
Is your goal simply prediction, or is our goal to understand mechanism?
And for that, I would want additional measurements.
But I think as a field, with the explosion of technology, we have to think.
We always have to ask do we need more?
And the session that I was in yesterday, one of the speakers was
how much do we need? Essentially. How much can we get?
But first we have to have some of these atlases with linked outcomes
if we want to assess that. And then I suspect it will transfer also to some degree
across tissue types. Maybe not all, and maybe not all
interventions. Yes. Hello.
Christina, good to see you. Great talk. Lauren Blair, AstraZeneca.
It's possibly a naive question because this is not my forte, but is the
stiffness that you find at all correlated to breast density,
or is it completely...
Yes. And Val can comment because she I think covered this in
part in her talk. But Val, do you want to say a word?
Sorry I got here late.
No worries.
No, it's okay. We did separate studies, even with
mastectomy tissues where we did mammographic density afterwards
analysis, and then took little cores and analyzed
it. So we have pretty strong data saying that high
mammography density is associated with a stiffer
stroma. But in the context of a breast tumor, many
different cell types are contributing.
So I don't know if Christina has, from those data sets, whether
or not you could stratify on that.
Whether or not those individuals that showed
higher relapse were the ones that had
higher density.
I don't know if they gather all that info.
We don't have that data for that cohort.
I think we'd have to do it in a different cohort because-
Yeah
... they were just primary tumors at that point.
But I think it's a really important question for risk.
And that's the point that you were making, Val.
And I think there was a beautiful link.
Dennis really clearly showed this link between genome and stability, and how does
that all relate to the stiffness and the context in which these lesions
arise. I think that's a huge question.
But I think one that the community will have to answer is how do we put all
these feature sets together when they haven't all been measured at the same time?
I'm personally optimistic that we're even getting towards some of these data sets.
So hopefully we can start to address that.
I think it's important to realize that
even if you have high density breasts, because 10% of the women in the world have
dense breasts, but 10% of the women don't get breast cancer.
So there's clearly many other factors that contribute
that we need to parse out.
So happy to, we're all going to be here and you can ask us
questions afterwards. I need to actually close the session.
Thank you.
I want to thank the speakers and the audience for
sticking around and being stalwart
participants. All these other people are running away.
So thank you for coming. Thank you for your questions.
And hopefully, we'll have some cool science going forward.
And I will say this again, 10 years from now,
mechanics and mechanobiology will be
basically the core. It'll be involved.
It'll be one of the major hallmarks. That's my hope.
Thank you very much. Bye.